the high-stakes day for president biden
sitting down with allies to discuss the
war in ukraine the president is meeting
today with nato g7 and european union
leaders in brussels
in brussels
brussels belgium mr biden is expected to
unveil new sanctions against russia for
its aggression and new aid for ukraine
ukrainian president vladimir zielinski
addressed the nato meeting virtually
nato says it's sending troops to
bulgaria hungary romania and slovakia
nato members that used to be soviet
satellites the move effectively doubles
the number of battle groups along nato's
eastern flank close to russia for the
first time yesterday secretary of state
anthony blinken formally accused russia
of committing war crimes in ukraine
including an attack on a maternity
hospital
cbs news foreign policy and national
security contributor h.r mcmaster joins
us now the retired three-star general
served as national security advisor in
the trump administration general it's
good to see you again good morning
hey vlad great great to be with all of
you thank you so general let me ask you
about this nato is doubling the number
of troops at its border with ukraine
nato has also vowed not to fight russia
directly in ukraine president zielinski
in a speech is asking for clarity on the
help that he's called for what's the
purpose of doubling those troops if
nato's not going to get involved
well first of all we're trying to deter
further aggression i mean you know i'll
tell you vlad i think you know we're
like it seems like we're in 1939 and
when poland was under assault you know
initially by you know the nazis and then
by the by the soviet union and so i
think a lot of these measures are
designed to ensure that the conflict
doesn't expand but i think what's
encouraging what's encouraging is is the
doubling down on more and more support
for the ukrainians who i mean who cannot
help but inspire us with with their
courage with their resilience uh and and
standing up to this aggression and and
uh you know it's the saddest situation
any of us could imagine right who
thought
many people thought hey this era was was
done this is from the past this kind of
carnage that we're seeing so i think the
the uh the demonstration of unity in
brussels is super important uh the
commitment to deterring further conflict
but i think especially vlad i would i
would emphasize the doubling down on
support for the ukrainians
you know general you mentioned 1939 even
in my first army rotc class i learned
that since 1938 1939 the strategy of any
military is to take out airfields take
out airports uh ensure that your forward
supply troops are being supplied in the
rear use air power to conduct those
attacks the russians haven't been doing
that
we've seen interceptions of cell phone
messages between russian commanders on
the ground what's the strategy there
does it appear to you that ukraine can
actually win this even without nato
support
absolutely and vlad when we talked about
this almost a month ago i i mentioned at
the time russia has already failed i
mean they failed in terms of their
initial objectives to try to subjugate
all of ukraine they didn't have the
forces and what they've demonstrated is
really a high degree of military
incompetence and their ability to
conduct you know fire and maneuver and
as you know from your you know from your
time as well in rotc that that you know
to integrate all arms into the fight and
and uh but but you know of course what's
sad about this and what we can't we
can't get too happy about you know the
problems that russia has encountered
what they've done is they've fallen back
on a pretty simple task you know which
is just to rubble cities right to
bombard
uh cities and and to inflict casualties
on innocent civilians and this is really
what nato's got to focus on i mean
we talk about individual weapons systems
should they have migs or not migs and so
forth but what's really important is to
ensure that the russian military can no
longer
bomb cities and inflict mass casualties
on innocents with impunity
yeah i think people are surprised of the
ineptitude of the russian military so
far i'm also surprised that vlad was in
an rotc class but that's a whole nother
conversation i'm like what like
but as you know general the u.s has
declared this uh declared putin a war
crime
declared what is happening here a war
crime does this mean
that the u.s should change its strategy
here since they've made that declaration
that's very unusual
gail i i think so right so i you know
what's hap what's happening is is
horrible right we're all you know our
hearts are broken for the ukrainian
people
25 one in four of ukrainians are
displaced right now right we have you
know approaching now four million
refugees and the projections are that if
russia can continue to bombard the
population centers that maybe they're
going to kill a million people maybe
there'll be 10 million people who are
refugees so i think what's really
important and i hope this is what's
happening in in brussels right now is
let's do right now what we would do
after putin kills a million people and i
think it's really important to do
everything we can
to address this humanitarian catastrophe
i think our objectives ought to be you
know hey first of all ensure vladimir
putin fails right because if he doesn't
fail in ukraine this isn't the end of
this right and and the second objective
is to mitigate the humanitarian
catastrophe of course we want to prevent
escalation there's been a lot of talk
about that
and then finally i i think you know we
can we can bend this situation in a way
that
that shifts the balance in the world
away from these authoritarian powers on
the eurasian landmass china and russia
and back toward the free world and in
our in our democratic and free and open
societies
general uh the bible administration is
warning that russia will ramp up cyber
attacks on ukraine in the u.s why
haven't we seen cyber attacks from
russia yet
well you know we don't really know do we
this is like this is the dog that hasn't
barked and and i think a lot of it
probably has to do with the ukrainians
are pretty darn capable and and i think
that they probably had and i'm
speculating i don't have i'm not privy
to any any sort of classified
information on this but i think they
probably went after the russians pretty
effectively and i think the russians are
probably back on their heels a bit uh in
in cyberspace and and of course you know
in cyberspace this isn't just a new
thing right we are we have been under
attack every single day
by the russians and of course we have an
extremely capable cyber force ourselves
so i don't know what my friend general
paul nakasoni is doing as the as the
director of the nsa but we couldn't have
a better person actually in the lead of
that organization so you know we can't
be complacent obviously you know it's
pretty easy to destroy as we know yeah
we have a lot of surface area to attack
and and and the the attacker in
cyberspace has some advantages so we we
have to we have to develop more and more
resilient systems right we're behind
already uh but then also i think we're
probably undertaking some offensive
capabilities right in cyber space you
have to you have to you have to try to
shoot down the arrows that are coming at
you but you have to also be able to go
in and kill the archer
yeah general it's always great to talk
to you sir thank you very much for
appearing with us we appreciate it
great to be with you thank you